and welcome to the daily climate show
coming up
drought and looming famine in somaliland
a warning from the u.n of potential mass
death of children
going in the right direction but not
fast enough record investments in
renewable energy
and bring back the bees the eu plan for
nature recovery
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show here on sky news where we report on
the impacts of the climate crisis
hearing from those worst affected and
follow the people working on the big
solutions
well we start today with a stark warning
about drought and famine in the horn of
africa if an intervention doesn't happen
quickly the united nations children's
fund says it's inevitable that many
children will die in the coming months
in april the self-declared republic of
somaliland issued an emergency appeal
for assistance for the one and a half
million people affected by the drought
the number of people in need is up 85
since the start of the year
or more than 100 schools have had to
shut their doors due to the lack of
water
and all across somaliland and somalia
since the start of the year there's been
more than 3 000 cases of cholera and
more than 6 000 cases of measles our
international affairs editor dominic
waghorn reports from rural villages and
the self-declared republic of somaliland
and a warning this report does contain
images of distressed children
on what looks like the surface of mars
the worst drought for 40 years is taking
hold
on land parched dry people are
struggling to survive
or fleeing
villages are emptying in this one
two-thirds of people have already left
but some are too sick to move like
little decker
seven weeks old and severely
malnourished
her mother ian was also weak and
struggled to speak
the family is running out of food their
livestock has either died or stopped
producing milk like so many others here
under baking heat we met ismael mahmud
who's lived here 90 years and says it's
the worst drought he's ever witnessed
[Music]
the deeper inland the worst the drought
we drove by one homestead after another
deserted by families as the drought
claimed their livestock
and this is the the main homestead
and
probably they had children's here they
gave birth to children's here one two
three kids here
and so you only leave if you have to
yeah yeah that is
it's the worst
in the worst situation and they you know
that is the last thing they can do
living leaving their homes they had to
leave they're not they had no choice
truly they had no choice
outside one village we met the governor
of the region
its people desperately need help he told
us but the drought he says is being made
worse by the war in ukraine
it may look busy but in the only big
flower mill in somaliland they are
running out of grain
russia's blockade of ukraine means they
haven't had a shipment for three months
its silos are emptying and they may soon
have to stop grinding grain
maybe everybody will lose his job
also uh uh
somalia population how they will get
food in general this war affected us as
a company as a company we are affected
by this war
that's it
if the mill shuts down somaliland will
lose its main source of bread
it's hard to think of a more graphic
illustration of the impact of russia's
war in ukraine on developing nations one
of the world's poorest countries
literally running out of grain it's
silos standing empty while there is
millions of tons of grain stuck in
ukraine unable to get out
war and droughts now haunt somaliland
and the entire horn of africa
threatening a humanitarian disaster
unicef says without action the mass
death of children will be inevitable and
the people here know it's coming
the last of three wells in this village
to have any water left camel herders had
dire predictions
the drought is bad he says but worse is
on its way
dominic waghorn sky news somaliland
well let's get some more of today's
climate news for you now and the
european commission has proposed legally
binding targets to restore nature across
the european union in an attempt to
recover plunging wildlife populations
they'll also be individual targets to
help specific species and habitats for
example pollinators like bees and
farmland birds and to restore rivers
back to their natural courses
while the proposals would require eu
countries to restore nature to 20
of eu land by 2030.
the united states continues to face an
intense heat wave temperatures are
likely to reach nearly 40 degrees
celsius today in cities like atlanta and
charlotte as the heatwave moves
eastwards the unusually hot conditions
will likely remain until the end of the
month the extreme heats are likely to
test the country's energy supply too
with one power grid operator saying it's
taking steps to ensure supplies aren't
disrupted as people turn on their air
conditioning
here household energy bills in the uk
are likely to increase by around 2.7
billion pounds to cover the cost of the
28 energy supplies that have gone bust
in the last year and this doesn't take
into account the collapse of bulb energy
which might land another multi-billion
pound charge on consumers the national
auditor office has said that while the
failures were caused by the massive
changes in the energy market the
regulator of gem is also partly to blame
now europe needs to prepare for the
possibility of russia
cutting off its gas supplies completely
that's according to the head of the
international energy agency
fatty beryl's comments come as his
agency's report shows record amounts of
spending is going into clean energy
sources but not enough to plug the gap
in supply caused by the ukraine wall
we'll discuss all of this in a minute
but let's first take a look at the
details of this iea report investment in
clean energy was quite flat despite the
paris agreement in 2015 when countries
vowed to move away from fossil fuels but
since 2020 that spending has actually
grown by 12
and it's estimated to rise even more
with the iea expecting clean energy
investment to nearly one and a half
trillion dollars this year this is
mostly spending on renewable power like
wind and solar but more money is
also going into emerging technologies
investment in battery energy storage is
set to double to almost 20 billion
dollars this year plus commercial scale
carbon capture projects are also taking
off with 130 announced in 20 different
countries in 2021
and of course the war in ukraine is also
having an impact as europe turns away
from russian oil companies focused on
hydrogen which is also a clean energy
source of course are now raising half a
billion dollars a year well joining me
now is jill duggan from the
environmental defense fund in europe um
thanks very much for joining us on the
daily climate show i want to talk to you
first about um fatty beryl's comments um
jill
he's actually saying that because of
this potential disruption of gas supply
from russia
countries really should start looking to
keep their nuclear power plants that
they might have potentially
decommissioned opened for longer what do
you make of that
well i think we do need to look at all
available sources of energy as you've
already demonstrated in in earlier
stories people are facing um very high
energy costs this year and nuclear does
have the the benefit of being carbon
free although it does have other uh
costs and issues associated with it
so i think that that's one of the
sources that needs to be borne in mind i
thought the report was very interesting
though for showing that that increase in
investment in clean energy actually a
lot of that increase was uh taken up by
increased costs so it wasn't all
translating into that amount of clean
energy
that the investment would suggest it's
worrying though isn't it because the
statistics right now are seemingly so
much better than they were post-paris
agreement as we just saw in that graphic
but it's simply still not enough what
more do you think needs to be done and
can be done
i think one of the start things that
comes through in the report is the
difference between developed and
developing countries so most of that
investment in clean energy is happening
in developed countries and china and the
developing countries investment is very
much
clean energy investment is very flat
they don't have the same resources and
if we really want to tackle this climate
crisis we will have to make sure that
those finances flow to those countries
in order to to allow them to increase
their renewable energy sources
i think the other thing finances
in terms of the types of energy sources
renewable i mean there's a lot of focus
on solar and wind but beyond that we
just mentioned hydrogen and other
sources can you tell us about what types
of energy needs to be invested in
well i think all of the above but i
think one of the things i would like to
point out is we need to be very aware
when we're making these investments and
not everything is what it what it
appears at first glance so hydrogen can
play an important role but even green
hydrogen made from renewable energy
renewable electricity so it can have a
global warming impact if we don't make
sure that we use it effectively so none
of these is a silver bullet we need to
think about what we're doing and with
renewable sources it's very important
they're very place-based you know if
you've got a lot of sun then solar is
obviously the first place to look if you
have a lot of wind or or tidal then you
know those those are other alternatives
um the other thing that is extremely
important is you know making our
buildings and our industries and our
appliances as efficient as possible we
need to get you know as much as we can
out of the electricity that we produce
so we need to make sure those renewables
are really working hard for us
jill duggan executive director from the
environmental defense fund europe thanks
very much indeed for joining us on the
daily climate show
thank you
and that's all from us for now thanks
for watching